if you want to hear about the true
meaning of us and what everything
represents then stick around to the end
of this video
Jordan peels us deals with a
subterranean society of doppelgangers
who rises up to take their place in the
sunlight the concept of literal
underground societies has been creepy
and fascinating to me ever since I found
out that these so-called mold people
actually exist yeah this is a real thing
and fuels pairing of that with another
creepy concept doppelgangers is bound to
leave moviegoers looking something like
this the movie opens with a text card
telling of the thousands of miles of
tunnels unused subway systems service
tunnels and mine shafts with no known
purpose the first image we see is the
main character Addie watching TV as a
young girl in 1986 she's watching the
Channel 11 News one of the many
references to the number 11 seen
throughout the movie welcome back to the
meaning of eleven later on first there
are some Easter eggs on the side of the
TV there's some VHS tapes and they may
be there to honor some of the films that
helped inspire us one of them is chud a
1984 movie about subterranean creatures
who abduct people the relevance of that
one should be pretty obvious and
unlikely to bring anyone down there
[Music]
there's also a tape of The Goonies in
1985 kids film and watch a group of
children must search for pirate's
treasure in an underground cavern just
as the mother and us must venture
underground to find her abducted son The
Last Tape I could make out was the right
stuff which is a nonfiction movie about
the development of the space program and
I'm guessing that it's loosely related
because venturing underground is similar
to space travel and that you're setting
out into an unknown frontier the news on
the TV goes to commercial and she
watches an ad for Hands Across America
the few seconds that this is on screen
are the key to understanding this entire
phone I understood everything a little
bit better when I went home and looked
up what Hands Across America actually
was and what it stood for Hands Across
America was a charity event that took
place in 1986 participants would donate
$10 to reserve their spot as Americans
lined up in joined hands for 15 minutes
theoretically creating a chain from
coast to coast across the mainland
United States the goal of the event was
a raise money and awareness to help
combat hunger and homelessness when addy
goes to the Santa Cruz Beach Boardwalk
with her parents as a little girl she's
wearing a Hands Across America shirt and
it becomes one of her last solid
memories of the real world when she's
abducted by the shadow people at the
carnival her dad wins her a Thriller
t-shirt which he puts on over it as they
explore the boardwalk Eddie sees various
carnival activities that are significant
her father wants to ride the roller
coaster which he calls the Little Dipper
in real life it's called the Giant
Dipper
[Music]
this is either a reference to the idea
that Adi is gonna be dipping or
descending into this underground world
or another way of looking at it is that
the Big Dipper and Little Dipper are
constellations and while those above the
surface can see and observe the Stars
the tunnel dwelling doppelgangers cannot
there even a couple of lines throughout
the movie about the joy of being able to
gaze at the stars they also walked by
and noticed in people playing a
whack-a-mole arcade game a visual
representation of the people on the
surface knocking those who live
underground back down forcing them to
stay there before wandering off the
boardwalk addy sees a sign that says
jeremiah 11:11 and this has multiple
meanings 11:11 represents two sets of
doubles it's also symmetrical and it's
the only time in a digital clock that
appears the exact same in front of a
mirror this is assuming that they're
slashes through the zeros as there
should be in culture 11:11 is often
considered a lucky or magic number and
I'll be talking more about the
references to magic throughout this
video but the sign specifically
references Jeremiah 11:11 a biblical
verse that reads therefore thus says the
Lord behold I am bringing disaster upon
them and they cannot escape though they
cry to me I will not listen to them and
this could be seen as a religious
prediction of the bloodshed that will be
brought on by the uprising of the
doppelgangers the last thing we see
before addy leaves the boardwalk is her
dad playing rock-paper-scissors to
settle a disagreement with her mom rock
paper and scissors each come back later
in the movie the main weapon used by the
shadow people is scissors but the Sun
and Jason uses a large rock to defeat
one of them when they flee to their
friends house across the lake then at
the end of the movie the fake version of
addy uses the sharp fire poker to defeat
the original addy who's wearing the red
jumpsuit and holding the paper cutouts
of people linking hands so this is kind
of a scissors beats paper moment when
addy walks off the boardwalk she goes
from the bright lights of the carnival
to the dark beach and there's also a
moment at the end of the movie when
they're battling underground and they
move from the lit up part of the hallway
into a stretch where the lights are off
the maze that Addie goes into on the
beach is called shamans Vision Quest
the tagline is find yourself and Addie
literally does find another version of
herself in that maze I also found it
interesting that it starts raining as
soon as she goes in because only the
surface dwellers can experience rain but
if you're a mole person and you're
watching this don't feel bad because at
least you guys don't have to
Sun spring so she wanders through the
mirror maze and the mirrors are another
huge motif in this movie the
doppelgangers are mirror images of the
humans on the surface and they're plenty
of examples of reflections as symbols
for the copies she goes through one part
in the forest where she sees these
distorted mirrors and that may be tied
to the fact that the Sun and the
underground family is distorted by the
burn marks on his face there are three
things that happen before she runs into
the doppelganger version of herself one
the lights go out and two all she can
see is the green exit signs reflected
hundreds of times in each mirror
although there appeared to be many exits
in reality she has no way out and three
she hears the doppelganger version of
herself
whistling remember those three things
because they'll be important later and
when that shadow girl does turn around
and see the original Addie the scene
cuts away before we see her being
abducted and the other girl switching
shirts with her and going onto the
surface now I know I'm not supposed to
have an opinion but in my opinion this
would have been more convincing if we
had seen her start running and then it
jump cut to her doppelganger getting
back to the parents and the boardwalk so
we think okay she made it back all right
but then in the reveal at the end of the
movie it shows the shadow Addie running
after her and dragging her back in
before joining the parents at the
boardwalk it would have made it a little
less obvious I think but instead it cuts
to the shot of the rabbits in cages so
let's talk about the meaning of rabbits
rabbits are often seen as a symbol of
reproduction because they're known to
reproduce very quickly the people
underground are reproductions of the
originals on the surface with scissors
sometimes being seen as an image
associated with a vasectomy the surgery
that prevents you from producing
offspring
there's also another idea that's
commonly associated with rabbits and
that's magic the most classic magician's
trick involves pulling a rabbit out of a
hat well it just so happens that the
shadow Addie grows up and has children
and her son Jason is interested in magic
tricks he has a lot of peculiar things
about him at the start of the movie he's
wearing a jaws shirts perhaps this is
just because jaws is a fellow Beach Set
horror movie but it could also have to
do with his fascination with the monster
he wears what I think is like a werewolf
mask throughout the entire film addy
also has a daughter
Zora who's wearing a shirt with a rabbit
on it and it seems to be only interested
in texting and a husband Gabe who
participates in cringe-worthy dabs and
has a love for boats that's not shared
by any of the other family members after
meeting the family we cut back to the
aftermath of Addie's childhood boardwalk
incident and discover that the
doppelganger version of her wouldn't
speak after being
by her parents who of course have no
idea that it's not the real her and
think that it's some kind of PTSD she
sees the meeting with the doctor through
a mirror I think that the reason that
she doesn't speak is because when the
Doppel come up from underground it takes
them some time to adjust to breathing
our fresh oxygen she's unable to speak
properly until her lungs have adapted to
the fresh air that's why when the
original adi comes back up to try to
take over the surface she sounds like
this there's further proof later on when
the family flees to the other house and
Gabe's friend's wife has seen screaming
and laughing in the mirror but no sound
comes out so as the family settles into
the beach house there were a few pieces
to note around the house there's a shot
of a spider crawling on the table under
a toy spider an early clue that the real
adi is crawling beneath and it's the
fake one that's on top on the surface
this imagery also connects with the song
that the doppelgangers whistle when they
arrive at the house the itsy-bitsy
spider
she expresses that she doesn't want to
go to the santa cruz beach not because
she was traumatized there as a child but
because she knows she'll be in close
proximity to the tunnel network and
she's afraid that something had happened
her walls are covered with artwork of
alvin ailey a known dance choreographer
and at the end of the movie it's
revealed that it was her dance recital
when she realized that she was in
control and she could be on the surface
it's as the doctor told Addie's parents
the best they can do for her is allow
her to draw write and dance Jason enjoys
playing inside the cabinet / closet the
door automatically locks when it's
closed so he props it up with his little
toy ambulance thing it's literally his
lifeline and also gaben's hora are saved
at the end of the movie when they come
across a real ambulance and get supplies
inside the closet I spotted games like
guess who magic and Candyland guess who
is literally a game where two identical
sets of people are lined up on opposite
sides not that different from the way
that this world is set up magic is
obviously a part of Jason's passion for
magic tricks and Candyland I guess
there's a version where the characters
are all rabbits but I didn't have that
one as a kid I had this one
it finds a rabbit doll in the drawer and
she's affected by it but it isn't
entirely clear why it's because it
reminds her of when she was trapped
underground until she made the switch so
they all get in the car and go to the
beach
Zora mentioned something about how she
thinks that the government is putting
fluoride in the water so that they can
control us a slight allusion to the fact
that they could all be controlled by
those living underground as they're
about to arrive a dead body is wheeled
onto another ambulance and this guy is
holding another Jeremiah 11:11 sign the
signals the beginning of everything that
happened that day at the boardwalk
repeating itself leading up to the
arrival of the tethered family there
long shadows as they walk onto the beach
signify that the shadow people are
drawing near the shamans Vision Quest is
now Merlin's forest another magic
reference
Gabe's friend Josh bickers with his wife
just as Addie's parents did on the
boardwalk all those years ago by the way
they have twin daughters another example
of mirrors they even have a moment where
they say the exact same thing at the
exact same time and then both jinx and
double jinx each other just like 1111
this is an example of a pair of doubles
the scene with them later at the house
pays homage to the Grady twins from the
shining I'm pretty sure the shining has
come up like three videos in a row now
and it actually comes up again later in
this video
Jason wanders off to go to the bathroom
and sees the guy posing or at least
that's what it looks like and I think
this is the first guy to come up from
underground and start the new hands
across america chain his mom freaks out
when he's gone because she knows about
the subterranean society and she's
afraid that Jason could be abducted when
they get home that evening Gabe is
watching the Giants game and if you
listen in to the audio in the background
you'll hear that the score is tied 1111
not long after when they tell their son
to go to bed the clock reads 11:11 p.m.
there's also a Lego ferris wheel in the
boys room a reference to the rides at
the beach boardwalk and a picture of
Merlin on his bedroom wall he's also
wearing a tuxedo shirt which makes him
look like a magician in uniform his
mother gets worried when she realizes
that he's drawing a picture of the T
posing man from the beach because she
possibly realizes what this is in the
bedroom she stares into her reflection
in the window as she expresses her
concerns to Gabe she tells him it feels
like a black cloud is hanging over her
she feels a storm coming very similar to
how it started raining when addy entered
the mirror maze all of those years ago
then the three things that happened back
then happen again the power goes out all
the exits are compromised and whistling
can be heard from the doppelganger when
we first see them they're all holding
hands like the hands across america
commercial the shadow people take over
the house and explain that they
basically don't have good lives down
below and they want their time in the
Sun they want to be untethered from the
bodies of the original family each
character goes off in battles the shadow
version of themselves the struggle
between the two mothers is symbolic
because Addie forces her doppelganger
into the glass table and we see it crack
representing the barrier between the two
versions of that character being broken
each character is able to fight off the
other version of them and together they
flee for Josh's family's house for help
but by the time they get there they've
already been taken over by the
doppelgangers one of Josh's last actions
is telling the virtual assistant to put
on Good Vibrations by the Beach Boys the
lyrics describe Addie's fascination with
the world on the surface
I love the colorful clothes she wears
and the way the sunlight plays upon her
hair I hear the sound of a gentle word
on the wind that lifts her perfume
through the air the next verse describes
the shadow Addie sensing the underground
uprising close my eyes she's somehow
closer now the other song that plays has
lyrics that are a little more on the
nose f Napoli's straight from the
underground this literally describes
what happens where the cops are unable
to help them because so many people are
being attacked from underground after
defeating the copies of the neighbors we
get that second shining reference that I
promised Jason just gets done saying
something about how there are too many
twins when they turn on the news and
discover that these people are
supposedly coming out of the sewers the
time is displayed on the bottom left
corner of the news overlay and it's now
237 a reference to room 237 in the
shining the family drives away in the
neighbors new car and they eventually
encountered Jason's doppelganger with
the mask again he's luring them into a
gasoline trap this part is a little bit
confusing but I think what's happening
here is that the two kids Jason and Zora
have the power to control the red suit
doppelgangers because they're both half
shadow people themselves so it would
appear that Jason uses that power to
walk backwards and drive his creepy
doppelganger back into the flames he
saves his family by doing so but it also
leads to him being kidnapped we also get
a look at the huge group of
doppelgangers linking
hands along the coast and the tea posing
guy from before has 1111 written on his
forehead which predicts more trouble so
Jason's mother goes down into the forest
maze to try to rescue him then the two
versions of adi face off underground i'm
gonna put everything together and talk
about what this movie actually means and
what it's trying to say so don't go
anywhere or someone will drag you
underground and you'll never come back
so during the final showdown adi
explains her three-decade plan how she
was abducted by the mole people she
basically put together her own hands
across america campaign she explains
that whoever created them was able to
duplicate their bodies but not their
souls which I believe is why their
violence to the surface dwellers because
only one of them can inhabit that soul
everything they have down below is just
a crappy simulation of real life but in
spite of that they are human too they
are made up of flesh and blood just like
those in the surface and they deserve an
equal experience and should not be
overlooked that leads us into what I
think us is trying to say as a movie the
people on the surface represent everyday
people leading normal lives in developed
countries sometimes they don't fully
appreciate what they have in the scene
where the shadow family breaks into the
house adi describes the differences
between those who live on the surface
and those underground the surface people
get warm delicious meals while the
subterranean society has to eat cold raw
rabbits the kids on the surface get nice
toys but the toys underground are cold
and spiky she also describes the
differences between the two seemingly
parallel families she tells the story of
a girl who had a shadow how they were
connected tethered together the girl
married a prince although the family
sees gabe as sometimes jealous of his
friend's car house and boat constantly
one-upping him a family such as the
Doppel family would be happy with what
he has she also describes how the girl
in the story gave birth to a son Jason
is sometimes criticized for being a bit
strange and wearing a monster mask but
the shadow girl gave birth to an actual
monster who acts like a real beast and
needs to wear a mask to cover up his
scars the idea is to be happy with what
you have and not lose sight of the fact
that there are less fortunate people
among you maybe even
just as Hands Across America was
organized all those years ago the people
living underground revived it in a much
bigger way to bring attention to the
cold sad lives that those born
underground are subjected to by staging
their own movements the final shot of
the movie is a huge sweeping overhead
shot showing the massive amount of
people in red jumpsuits forming a Hands
Across America chain the shot is very
reminiscent of the 1986 commercial that
was shown to us at the very beginning of
the movie of course if you have another
interpretation of this movie or any
things that I might have missed in this
video be sure to let me know in the
comments and check out the playlist on
the left to see all the things you might
have missed in the trailers for the
upcoming horror movie Pet Sematary
remember to subscribe to seize these
world for new Horrors every week bring
that death belt for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive